on station mais le plus dur reste à
venir c'est expliquer exactement ce
qu'est ce fameux internet sans que la
nique avec michel jeannot latos le bon
vieux minitel relégué au musée de la
communication
désormais grâce à internet voici par
exemple services télématiques de france
2 en couleurs et en images qui bougent
seules conditions techniques pour
accéder à internet avoir un ordinateur
équipé d'un modem de connexion et avoir
un téléphone
l'intérêt majeur d'internet c'est de
pouvoir se relier au world wide web la
toile d'araignée tissée entre tous les
ordinateurs du monde entier
d'un simple clic de souris vous pouvez
entre en contact instantanément avec les
régions les plus reculées de la planète
vous ne savez pas quel métro prendre à
paris à lille ou à new york
l'université française de jussieu
propose au monde entier les parcours et
les plans et transports urbains vous
êtes loin de la france où vous n'avez
pas la radio dans votre bureau
rien ne vous empêche d'écouter les
informations sur france info et si vos
préoccupations sont plus frivole ce ne
sont pas les sites rose plus ou moins
hard qui manque ce qui d'ailleurs pose
le problème des limites de la liberté
sur internet
faut-il tout autorisé peut-on interdire
car contrairement au minitel l'accès à
internet n'est pas possible directement
il faut obligatoirement souscrire un
abonnement auprès d'un intermédiaire
qu'il s'appelle aol compresseur ou
wanadoo cela vous coûtera environ 150
francs par mois auxquels il faut ajouter
le prix de la communication téléphonique
local